we see an enormous shortage of stem
trained undergraduates but to your point
it's a real lack of diversity our
engineering team is desperate to hire
people with more sort of the team
themselves say look we are mainly you
know fantastic white men we want more
diversity of thought we want more
creativity in our team and actually what
we're starting to do now is try to take
our technology into the school into high
schools into undergraduates into medical
schools and try and bring that sort of
inspiration about science because
talking about sequencing you're not just
talking about biology or talking about
experimental design you'll talk about
engineering you'll talk about data
analysis you're talking about
communication you're talking about
policy ethics there are so many ways to
bring these skills earlier so that you
are more people feeling more included by
the science journey through education I
completely agree with you Mark we can
get more people more educated get more
kinds of creativity into that Innovation
Journey if I could just add to that and
it goes a bit to the point I think Mark
you were making earlier which is so much
Innovation is happening on the cusps of
different discipline and we have I think
in the University sector been quite good
at bringing various different
disciplines together we could probably
be better but I think there's a there's
a sort of another element is are we good
enough at allowing scientists to spend a
little bit of time in the pockets of
policy makers and corporates and so on
as part of their scientific education
and in my experience the answer is no
people tend to stay in their silos and
if they collaborate they might do so
with another University department but
they're unlikely to do so with a
corporate or with a government body and
that I think to me is something we ought
to be thinking a bit about I agree with
that completely Daniel I I think that
the financial incentives uh in the
University sector don't make it easy for
people to move around in that way and I
agree with you I think I think it's
another issue in it it's not only Early
Education it's actually people in
postdocs many of whom will not go on to
be research leaders in universities
there isn't I think enough emphasis on
Skilling them for all the different
opportunities as there are and you know
frankly if you are a scientist and you
are inquisitive you know how to ask
experiments you understand statistics
and you you have to be a good
communicator those are the skills for
almost every Walk of Life